as we mark the end of gay pride month we
want to introduce you to a mom dedicated
to changing the world
one hug at a time sarah cunningham
started a group called free mom hugs the
goal is to make sure every member of the
lgbtq plus community feels loved even if
it's not by someone in their own family
lead national correspondent david bagno
shows us how the group is having a
profound impact and doing it with this
one simple gesture
oklahoma city had a pride fest that was
filled with all the music rainbow flags
and love you could want to find thanks
in part to sarah cunningham happy pride
baby and her group free mom hugs you
have moms and dads and friends and
allies by the thousands my parents are
not supportive of me being gay so it
just felt good to have somebody say that
but cunningham who grew up a devout
christian
did not always embrace the lgbtq plus
community in fact when her son parker
now 33 years old came out to her when he
was a teenager the mother of two
rejected him i really thought that he
was gonna burn in hell for eternity and
i thought if i accepted this about him
that made me just as much of a sinner
than he is you never forget
i mean things that were said or things
that were done but it's through kind of
telling our story together that i think
has really helped us um
just understand the journey better so
many kids who are gay don't even have
the courage to say it to their mother he
did and you still didn't welcome it
that's not to apply
it's to tell people watching
to not do it
he was sharing the most tender intimate
part of himself
and i denied him that
that still haunts her the guilt that he
probably felt and i certainly do now and
we've worked through a lot of things so
but you can't get rid of those memories
she went through some pretty deep soul
searching and that is what led to a
change of heart i could not reconcile
what i learned as a loving god
who created
my son that he would cast him into hell
was there a moment where you said to him
i hear you
and i accept you
parker and his friend were here and we
were in the backyard and his friend
was sharing a story and i could see
self-harm marks on his arm
and he shared about how he had been
alien alienated from his family
in his church
group and it was there that
i just felt such unconditional love
for that person i hardly knew
and she never forgot it
in 2015 she started free mom hugs and
she's been hell bent on showing up for
the lgbtq plus community consistently
you could have helped serve food you
could have marched in the parade like
why a hug that's a really good question
i'm a hugger and it allowed me to give
love in a way that a mother should and
it has evolved from there in 2018
cunningham took to social media writing
if you need a mom to attend your
same-sex wedding because your biological
mom won't call me i'm there how many
people called you people from all around
the world
said i'll show up to i'll stand in
really yeah all over the world
cunningham has officiated or served as a
stand-in mom at more than a dozen
weddings have you lost friends doing
this yes family yes have they come back
only when someone they love comes out
and that's all right
when i was
the mom like me then
i needed someone who shared my faith to
tell me it's okay to search the matter
out
melissa williams turned to cunningham
after learning that her daughter was a
lesbian can i offer you a hug williams
is now the co-leader of the texas
chapter of free mom hugs have the best
time we love you happy pride y'all last
weekend she drove the two hours to
oklahoma city to give some hugs this
makes me cry for herod aspen whose
mother passed away before she came out
the connection is one that she longed
for having somebody who represents a mom
just being accepting and loving is
extremely
important and
people like me and others that i know
just
one hug means everything it makes my
eyes water when i think of the love
and the outpouring of just community
this is what it's all about in the
nearly 10 years since she gave her first
mom hug sarah cunningham is now
traveling parts of this country with her
son
shedding her shame forgetting her fear
and joining in in the joy
you feel loved very loved
love
has come full circle over the course of
this interview you have said in a
roundabout way about three times the
lord said to me
and it's occurring to me that
you got all twisted up about what people
said the lord meant yes rather than
directly what the lord was telling you
to do yeah and that's what i couldn't
reconcile yeah
that's sweet i never heard it said that
way thank you david
free mom hugs has become a nationwide
movement with chapters in all 50 states
sarah is hoping that one day there are
going to be chapters
all over the world
david i love this um well done you know
i look at you like family so i hope
these questions aren't too personal but
when did you come out and do you
remember
your first hug of acceptance
well it's interesting i never expected
to be asked this question on national
television but more importantly i never
expected to be honest about it um i came
out at 24 and i remember nate it's funny
you ask i was about 17 i was in high
school and i was a speech coach jose
sarat who pulled me into her classroom
one day and she said what are you
running from and it was the first time
someone essentially said to me what
happened to you rather than what's wrong
with you what's wrong with you and it
led to an explosion of
stories and me breaking down my wall
that i built up for 24 years um wow but
we're so glad that sarah is doing what
she's doing i was very touched when she
said that people uh change when someone
they love comes out today i was struck
by that i was really struck by that
because she said you asked her and yeah
friends and she said yes they come back
only when someone they know or someone
in their family comes out to them david
yeah bingo you know guys she wrote a
memoir go ahead go
well all of us have someone in our own
family you may not know it you may not
know it but all of us have someone we
know in our own families that's that's
the reality of the world we live in
today so i'm so glad she's bringing this
message go ahead david sorry for her
it's parker no that's okay jamie lee
curtis actually is going to be making
sarah's story a memoir she wrote into a
movie and jamie lee is going to be the
the lead in that movie and one more
thing you may be wondering at home i
wonder if she still goes to church
she does she's still a christian she's
still proud of it but she goes to an
affirming church because she said david
i'm never going back to a place that
tells me loving my son for exactly who
he was born to be
is wrong
amen to that amen to that david i
remember you and i were anchoring
together on cbs news streaming when the
supreme court ruled in favor of same-sex
marriage that was such a proud moment
for you i remember we we high-fived each
other even though we're objective
journalists uh we high-fived each other
on the air and it was an incredible
moment and at the end of pride month i
just want to wish you a happy pride
month
happy pride it was great to spread to
you know have that moment with you vlad
and happy pride i never thought this kid
from louisiana would be able to say that
on national television so that's a full
circle moment for me happy pride give
the best hugs by the way yeah i'll give
you a big one when i see you again that
kid from louisiana is doing a-okay
a-okay david always good to see you
thank you